So last week I mentioned that I would be significantly
limiting my coverage of the so-called Obama
gate scandal because floating these conspiracy
theories is how Donald Trump wins.
It's how Trump distracts.
It's how Donald Trump creates cover for himself.
And in this case, Donald Trump has failed
on coronavirus.
He's fired for inspectors general in the last
few months.
And the way Trump distracts from this is to
get media debating Obama gate, get media talking
about his supposedly taking hydroxy chloroquine.
So I'm going to do this today because there's
actually something to tell you about, which
is a leaked document that shows that Barack
Obama acted completely appropriately back
in 2016 and 2017 when it comes to the Michael
Flynn investigation.
Now, I also you know, there's people in my
audience who may not even really know what
the Obama gate scandal supposedly is.
Donald Trump clearly doesn't really understand
it.
He called it the greatest political crime
in the history of the United States.
And yet when he was asked for an explanation
of what crime was committed, Trump didn't
know where.
He refused to say.
And he went on to attack the journalists who
asked the question.
But generally and I don't want to spend an
hour on this because it's just not worth it.
But we do have news today.
Generally, Obama gate is related to the investigation
into Donald Trump's disgraced former national
security adviser, Michael Flynn and Michael
Flynn's eventual guilty pleas on on multiple
counts.
The allegations, generally speaking of Obama
gate, are Obama acted inappropriately.
He pushed law enforcement to do this or that
to Flynn.
Obama was the puppeteer of a political hack
job on Flynn in order to attack Trump, even
to remove Trump.
And it was all illegal.
Despite the fact that we still don't have
clarity on what crimes supposedly were even
committed.
If you really want to know more about the
details, you can find them.
But it's just not even worth explaining it
to you.
We now have a released unredacted memo from
Barack Obama's then national security advisor,
Susan Rice.
This is what's called a contempt contemporary
or contemporaneous memo.
It's dated Friday, January 20, 2017.
It's a summary of her notes from the January
5th meeting.
That is the center of a lot of this.
And again, I sort of don't want to go deep
on this because it's a huge waste of time.
But I want to get some of this on the record
for everybody in the letter, in the memo that
Susan Rice wrote.
She says there was a briefing from the intelligence
community about Russian hacking during 2016.
And after that briefing, there was a meeting
which she participated in.
The meeting involved President Barack Obama.
Then FBI Director James Comey, Deputy Attorney
General Sally Yates, Obama's national security
advisor, Susan Rice, who wrote this memo,
and vise President Joe Biden.
So good, we know who was there.
Susan Rice goes on to say, President Obama
began the conversation by stressing his continued
commitment to ensuring every aspect of this
issue is handled by the intelligence and law
enforcement communities, by the book.
OK.
The president stressed he is not asking about
initiating or instructing anything from a
law enforcement perspective.
He reiterated that our law enforcement team
needs to proceed as it normally would.
By the book, it goes on to say, Obama wants
to ensure that in their interactions with
the incoming Trump administration, they know
if there are reasons they should not share
information fully about Russia.
James Comey then confirmed they will go by
the book and added that he has some concerns
that incoming national security adviser Michael
Flynn is speaking more frequently than would
be normal or typical with Russian Ambassador
Sergei Kislyak.
And it could be an issue when it comes to
sensitive information.
Comey said potentially the outgoing administration,
the Obama administration, should be careful
about passing sensitive information related
to Russia to Michael Flynn because of the
unusual level of communication between Flynn
and the Russian ambassador.
It's there in black and white.
Obama wanted nothing special.
Comey had these concerns, period.
There is no crime there, particularly on the
behalf of Barack Obama.
The only shocking thing about this letter
is how a politically and professionally Barack
Obama handled this, which I know seems inconceivable
in the era of Donald Trump.
Now, there's a few other things to mention.
Barack Obama warned Donald Trump about Michael
Flynn during the transition period.
If Barack Obama were involved in shady business,
why on earth would he call attention to it
by mentioning Michael Flynn to Donald Trump?
Why go to Trump and say, be careful with Flynn
if.
Obama is the one working on a criminal trumped
up bogus hack job of Michael Flynn.
It makes no sense.
Now, lastly, there are people arguing that
the proof that the FBI entrapped Michael Flynn
is there are notes from January 24th before
Michael Flynn interrogation where they said
one of the goals of this interrogation is
to get Michael Flynn to lie.
And there are people who are wildly saying
that's proof that it was a setup.
This is a perjury trap.
This is entrapment.
I hate to break it to you guys, but this is
nothing controversial.
These are FBI notes in advance of an interrogation
about their goals for the interrogation.
It's done all the time.
Flynn had already lied at that point.
And what they are making reference to here
is they want to get Flynn's repeated lie on
the record.
This is not a perjury trap.
There is also a perjury trap has a very narrow
definition, and it's when there is no reason
to suspect a crime has been committed.
And you bring someone in for an interview
only to get them to lie absent any information
that they've already lied in the past or have
been potentially involved in any other crime.
Nine hundred and ninety nine out of a thousand
times when the term perjury trapped is perjury
trap is used, it simply does not apply.
Michael Flynn lied multiple times.
He pleaded guilty to two counts.
He had denied that he told Kislyak to back
off from escalating the situation in response
to sanctions.
That was a lie.
He lied about a follow up phone call.
I think there was a third matter.
Flynn lied about that.
I now can't recall.
And given the number of lies that Flynn told,
he actually got a pretty damn good deal.
He's a retired U.S. general.
He got money from at least one foreign government,
Turkey.
He could have been charged with conspiracy.
He could have been charged with failure to
register as a foreign agent like his business
partner Feakin did.
And in the end, he he actually got a pretty
good deal.
Lastly, if James Comey had it in for Trump
and wanted Hillary to win and this Flynn thing
was part of that, why did Komi not once but
twice hold an optional press conference to
talk about the investigation into Hillary
Clinton's emails?
Not once, but twice, including right before
the November election?
It makes no sense.
It is a really dumb way for Komi to hurt Trump
and help Hillary to hold two press conferences
or press briefings.
Public statements talking about the investigation
into Hillary Clinton's emails.
So this entire Obama gate thing has backfired.
It has spectacularly imploded.
And very quickly, you are starting to see
the people around Donald Trump move on to
new things.
And it is all to distract from Trump's horrifying
pandemic response.
This is how Trump wins.
Every document that comes out shows that Barack
Obama certainly committed no crimes.
It shows James Comey handled this in a way
that corresponded with how you would have
to sensitively deal with something when, you
know you have an incoming national security
official that has to be investigated.
It has evaporated before our very eyes.